je vous présente mon chat elle s'appelle
ni trousse est une femelle
vous avez de la chance parce
qu'habituellement elle n'aime pas
beaucoup les caméras elle doit avoir
envie de faire une petite sieste un chat
dort en moyenne 12 à 16 heures par jour
principalement pendant la journée
comme beaucoup de ses activistes en
liberté nitro passe une grande partie de
la nuit dehors
même en plein confinement peut parcourir
des kilomètres dans l'obscurité
ça ne la dérange pas comme ses
congénères elle est ni talopp ses yeux
sont conçus pour voir dans la nuit je
vais vous montrer d'abord la pupille
possède un très grand rayon d'ouverture
ferme est ouvert pour capter un maximum
de lumière ico pris la ligne pour
récupérer le moindre petit rayon lumière
chez l'homme la lumière est captée par
des récepteurs situés sur la rétine
déconner des bâtonnets transforme la
lumière en signaux électriques qui sont
envoyées au cerveau via le nerf optique
libye
j'ai déjà c'est exactement la même chose
mais le fond de l'oeil du chat est en
plus tapissés d'une couche
réfléchissante le taper tous mpt qui
renvoie vers les récepteurs la lumière
qui est passé à côté
voilà pourquoi les chats voit mieux que
lui la nuit c'est ce qui explique ryan
moore pourquoi on voit très bien les
yeux de chat et quand ils passent dans
les phares d'une voiture
j'adore les yeux ni trop un peu de vert
en ce moment ça fait beaucoup de bien
comme une capsule de les confiner
si vous avez aimé cette capsule 2d
confiné n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleu vous pouvez également voir ou
revoir celle des jours précédents en
cliquant sur le côté gauche
j'en réalise une nouvelle par jour le
mieux pour ne pas en boucle et c'est de
vous abonner et d'activer la petite
cloche à très bientôt et n'oubliez pas
nous sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien